and we begin this morning with the
latest on those devastating California
wildfires the death toll has risen to at
least 71 in Northern California's
campfire about 1,000 people are reported
missing that blaze the worst in
California's history is now 50%
contained after consuming more than a
hundred and forty five thousand acres
just outside of Los Angeles the wolsey
fire is 78 percent contained after
burning 98 thousand acres now
communities are faced with a new and
very dangerous threat dense smoke from
those fires is smothering parts of the
state with what has been described as
the dirtiest air in the world Meg
Oliver's in Paradise California most of
which has been leveled by the campfire
last week Meg good morning Adrianna good
morning I'm standing in the middle of
that aftermath this used to be a
restaurant you can see that kitchen sink
behind me I landed in Sacramento just a
few hours ago that's about an hour and a
half from here and as soon as the doors
open you could taste and feel the thick
smoke even that far away President Trump
is expected to visit Northern California
later today but as communities begin to
assess this damage the worsening air
quality is imposing severe health risks
in Paradise a community destroyed by
flames is pledging to rise from the
ashes it's gonna be a tough rebuild but
I know the town of coming together and
we'll be able to put paradise back to
where it was it won't be easy
the campfire has burned more than 12,000
structures to the ground as it blazes
across Northern California and the death
toll is rising as authorities rushed to
sift through the debris an additional
eight human remains were recovered
during our search efforts today now the
winds that fueled the fire spread are
pushing thick smoke across the region
rendering the air virtually unbreathable
in neighboring cities it's horrible
it's so
you can smell the smoke and you can see
it I'm born and raised in Sacramento
this is the worst air we've had ever
people wore masks as hazardous smoke
levels blanketed the Sacramento Valley
yesterday posing health risks from
burning eyes to chronic heart and lung
diseases doctors say breathing it in is
the equivalent of smoking up to 10
cigarettes a day I got kind of
nauseating last night walking out in it
you know so tonight I have on a mass in
San Francisco the Bay Bridge was almost
completely obscured by the haze and in
Berkeley today's Stanford Cal football
game was postponed to protect athletes
from the severe conditions and the
problems won't go away for the more than
47,000 evacuees from the campfire
dozens of people are sick after multiple
norovirus outbreaks at Red Cross
shelters across the area Michelle just
one more challenge as these people tried
to move forward a lot of challenges for
them Thank You Meg Oliver stay safe in
Paradise California